bienvenidos hagamos el problema número
110 si unas barras de dulces se venden
normalmente a 40 centavos y ahora se
encuentran la oferta a 2 por 75 centavos
cuál es el porcentaje de descuento de
dos barras de dulce que se compraron en
oferta ok nos dicen que normalmente una
barra de dulce se vende en 40 centavos
se venden 2
75 centavos
cuál es la reducción en el precio de
estas dos barras o no a precio normal si
yo fuera a comprar dos barras estaría
pagando punto 80 porque es esta cantidad
por 20 puntos 80
y ahora bueno pues por dos barras pago
75 centavos esta diferencia entre el
punto 80 puntos 75 es de 5 centavos 5
centavos
lo que nos preguntan es el porcentaje de
descuento así que tenemos que ver estos
cinco centavos o lo expresó así punto 05
qué porcentaje son del precio original
de 80 centavos
voy a poner aquí 5 entre 80
hay que 8 me salió a ver vamos a
quitarlo 50 80 esta proporción cuales no
lo sé pues vamos a hacer la división
vamos a poner 5.000 para tener varios
ceros aquí con que trabajar y lo
dividimos entre 80 ok
subimos el punto
50 no me va a servir necesito usar 500
voy a poner 66 por 0 0 6 por 8 48 menos
500 me queda 20 bajo otro cero aquí
pongo 2 2 por 0 0 2 por 8 16
el resto me queda 40 bajo otro cero y
aquí pongo 55 por 0 08 por 540 y aquí me
queda mi división exacta entonces este
que es lo mismo que poner 6.25 por
ciento es el porcentaje de ahorro de
esta oferta y corresponde con mi opción
b
siguiente problema si ese es mayor que 0
y raíz cuadrada de r / s es igual a s
cuánto vale r en términos de s vamos a
elevar al cuadrado esta ecuación y nos
va a quedar raíz cuadrada de r / s al
cuadrado nos queda r entre ese igual a s
al cuadrado multiplicamos todo por ese s
por acá y multiplicamos hace por acá
estas dos se van y me queda que r es
igual a ese al cubo
y esta es mi opción de
siguiente problema 112 muy bien tenemos
esta gráfica y nos dicen que se tiene
una puerta de 6 x 8 metros con un marco
de latón que es esto que está sombrero
en verde de un metro de ancho uniforme
nos pregunta en qué fracción de la parte
frontal de esta puerta está cubierta con
latón ok entonces básicamente nos piden
el área que está en color verde que
llamamos sencillo sea calcular el área
que está en negro y restar la estar en
verde aunque bueno de esto no nos dan
los dimensiones
ok mejor vamos a encontrar esta área que
voy a subrayar aquí vamos a encontrar
primero esta área de aquí
luego bueno va a ser la misma al área de
aquí
y después vamos a encontrar el área que
está acá
que va a ser la misma que el área de
aquí
y que el área de acá sabemos que esto
vale un metro esta altura es 8 así que
el área de acabase por altura 8 por 1 es
igual a 8 metros cuadrados 8 metros
cuadrados esta área es igual a ésta
entonces aquí también voy a tener 8
metros cuadrados y ahora voy a calcular
el área de acá me dicen que toda esta
longitud es de 6 metros pero sé que esta
parte de aquí que es la que corresponde
al marco es de un metro y aquí también
hay otra fracción otro segmento de un
metro aquí hay un metro un metro
entonces a este 6 le voy a restar estos
2 metros por lo que esta parte de acá
me va a quedar de 4 metros y el ancho o
el alto de aquí es de 1 metro 4 x 14
tengo 4 metros cuadrados aquí también
porque estas tres áreas son iguales
aquí también también tengo 4 y aquí
tengo 4 y ahora lo que necesito hacer
pues es sumar todas estas áreas tengo
ocho más 8 16
444 es igual a 12 16 más 12 es igual a
28 metros cuadrados y nos están
preguntando la fracción de esta parte
frontal que está en amarillo en amarillo
no en vez de eso que está sombrero en
verde entonces voy a acercar el área
total de la puerta que es base por
altura 8 x 6
o 6 por 8 es igual a 48 este es el área
total de mi puerta
y quiero ver cuál es la fracción sabemos
que el área en verde es 28 así que es 28
entre 48 y simplificamos esto
vamos a tener que esto es 7 entre 12
que es nuestra opción de
muy bien siguiente problema número 113
y es igual a menos punto 3 cuál de las
siguientes opciones es verdadero las
opciones tienen combinaciones de a
ah qué bueno aquí nos dicen que es igual
a menos punto 3
a cuadrada a cuadrada es esto por x sí
mismo menos por menos es más punto 3 por
punto 3.0 9.09 i d y al cubo que es esto
x menos punto 3 menos 9 por 3 27 y
tenemos tres lugares después del punto
decimal
y es menos punto cero 27
de estos es el número más pequeño el
número más pequeño va a ser el más
negativo por decirlo de alguna manera y
este valor al menos punto 3 es el más
negativo si dibujáramos una recta
numérica así
y en esta recta pusiéramos los valores
que acabamos de encontrar aquí por
ejemplo ésta
2.09 por aquí va a estar el 0 por aquí
va a estar el menos puntos 0 27 y por
acá estará el menos punto 3
este es el que está más negativo más
hacia la izquierda entonces de las
opciones que nos dan la respuesta
correcta es a esta afirmación de que
dada es menor que a al cubo que a su vez
es menor que a cuadrada entonces a este
punto 9 es a cuadrada
este menos punto 27 es a kubica y este
menos punto 3 es a así que es menor que
a kubica y eso veces menor que a
cuadrado y esta es nuestra opción b
siguiente problema problema número 114
cuál de las siguientes es el producto de
dos enteros cuya suma da 11 nos dicen
básicamente que tenemos que encontrar
dos números equis más ya que al ser
sumados nos de 11 y nos preguntan cuál
será el producto de estos dos números
y quizás debamos experimentar ya que
podríamos tener números negativos
involucrados veamos voy a despejar de
aquí la voy a dejar sola y esto es igual
a 11 x y esto lo voy a sustituir acá voy
a reemplazar estas x por ye y sustituyó
esto 11 - x esto es igual a 11 x
- x al cuadrado
y aquí es puede tomar cualquier valor
entero veamos las opciones la opción a
es menos 42
- 42 esta es la opción
interesante puede obtener este número
multiplicando 14 x menos 3 esto es igual
a 14 x menos 3
este es un negativo y resulta que si yo
sumo 14 menos 3 me va a dar 11 14 menos
3 es igual a 11 está cumpliendo con lo
que estoy con lo que me están pidiendo
aquí bueno pues entonces es la opción
ojalá pudiera explicarle es mejor estas
pruebas intuitivas ya que simplemente
estoy experimentando con números si la
opción es menos 42 todos los posibles
factores de 42 son 12
es
76 por 7 42 aquí van estos 2 14 3 por 14
es 42 también es 21 21 por 12 42 y
obviamente también 42 que al
multiplicarlo por 142 y como es menos 42
alguno de estos números o de estos
factores va a tener que ser negativo y
como puede escogerlo de manera que la
suma de 11 pues ahí es cuando notamos
que tenemos este 14 y este 3
sí como nos tiene que dar 11 positivo
este número más grande va a tener que
ser positivo y este que es más pequeño
va a tener que ser negativo y así nos dé
al menos 42 a multiplicarlos y nos da 11
al sumar tío afortunadamente éste fue la
primera opción y no tuvimos que ir más
allá nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo